How popular is the Tax Cuts and Jobs Act,
Donald Trump's 2017 signature law,
and has it given the president a boost in the polls?
Very few pollsters ask people regularly about the law. The Economist/YouGov poll is an exception.
They've asked about it virtually every week
since passage, and the ratings are stable,
with opinion usually tilting slightly against the law.
In their latest online poll, 34 percent supported it
and 39 percent were opposed, with nearly
three and ten having no opinion.
In a March Fox News poll, 42 percent of
registered voters approved of the way
President Trump is handling taxes,
while 48 percent disapproved.
A Gallup poll from February 2019 also produced a negative verdict on Trump and taxes.
Public perceptions of the economy
have been very good lately,
and President Trump usually gets positive marks
from a majority of the public on handling it.
But rosy views about the economy are not changing in a positive way people's perceptions of the tax law.
Nor have they boosted views of the president on handling taxes.
What do you think about President Trump's Tax Cuts and Jobs Act?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.